this isn't the video I wanted to make
today I thought it was going to be about
how I bought a catamaran quit YouTube
and started sailing around the world
unfortunately though reality has
deviated from my projections despite
getting 3121 free tier signups and
selling one million 100 000 tokens with
zero dollars in infrastructure cost
thanks to the Firebase free tier and a
gross profit of 75.90 my side hustle is
still failing and if we can't turn the
ship around soon I'm going to have to
take it behind the barn
I'd expect anyone in this unit to do the
same for me in today's video we'll look
at everything that's gone wrong so far
but more importantly look at a variety
of strategies that you can use to
validate ideas and not things up
first of all though why is my side
hustle failing I made a 75.9 profit in
the first day which extrapolates to
twenty seven thousand dollars in annual
cash flow in addition the business runs
on autopilot and I haven't had to touch
the code since it went live that's great
and I'll likely keep it running
indefinitely from here as a zombie
project but here's why I'm not very
optimistic my conversion rate was only
0.3 percent that means I need to get 300
free users to sign up just to get one
paid user who's only paying 6.90 I'm
able to be profitable in the short term
because I have this YouTube channel
that's like a gravy train with biscuit
Wheels but I've already used up that Ace
in the Hole I've only had two additional
sales after the initial launch if I want
to keep pursuing this business I need to
either invest a lot of my own time into
organic marketing or pay a friendly
company like Google or meta an absurd
amount of money to appear on their
platform it depends on the industry but
it can cost hundreds of dollars just to
get one conversion if you have a product
that has a very high lifetime value it
can definitely be worth it to pay for
advertising because if you can pay for
ads while still being profitable then
there's really no reason not to in my
case though my product only costs 6.90
which would put me deep in the red with
paid ads but the one thing that's more
valuable than money is your time and I
don't want to spend my time standing on
the corner twirling a sign for the side
hustle behind almost every successful
small business is an extremely
passionate and driven founder if you're
going to try go all the way otherwise
don't even start this could mean losing
girlfriends wives relatives maybe even
your mind it could mean not eating for
three or four days it could mean
freezing on a park bench it could mean
jail it could mean derision it could
mean mockery isolation isolation is the
gift all the others are just a test of
your endurance of how much you really
want to do it and you'll do it despite
rejection and the worst odds and it will
be better than anything else you can
imagine if you're going to try go all
the way there's no other feeling like
that you will be alone with the gods and
the Knights will flame with fire you
will ride life straight to perfect
laughter it's the only good fight there
is if that Bukowski poem doesn't
describe how you feel about your project
then it might not be worth your time if
I'm being totally honest with myself I'd
much rather spend my time making content
on fireship than I would trying to build
up this half-assed voice cloning tool
that being said what could I have done
differently to make this project more
successful well first of all I only
spent two days building it it's not
responsive and has a terrible landing
page any meaningful minimum viable
project will take a lot longer than this
to develop even when using a highly
optimized Tech stack like the it or
suck it stack instead of using IBM
carbon as the design system I'd spend
more time creating a unique custom
design and have a much more powerful
call to action on the home page and I
should do a better job describing what
the product is in just a few words in
addition you want to use some kind of
analytics to understand how your users
are behaving because they're likely
using your app in ways you never
expected like Firebase itself was
originally supposed to be a chat which
it kind of like intercom but they found
that developers were putting all kinds
of random stuff in it so they decided to
Pivot to a real-time database then a few
years later it's acquired by Google
making them Rich beyond their Wildest
Dreams the Founders made their own luck
just like Tarantino to really optimize
things you should look at the analytics
then do some a b testing with a small
subset of users before you invest in a
huge launch and that's especially
important if you pay for ads because
then you really need to optimize that
conversion rate but we're getting ahead
of ourselves the big question is how do
you even come up with an idea for a side
hustle and then more importantly
validate it good ideas are easy to come
by the problem is that there's a hundred
billion people in the world if you
include the outer Lands Beyond the ice
wall and somebody out there is likely
already a millionaire with your idea the
fact that someone is already executing
your idea is actually a great way to get
some early validation big companies like
meta do this all the time by stealing
features from smaller applications in
fact it's a good sign that someone's
already doing your idea you just need to
figure out what they're doing wrong or
narrow down your target to find a
segment of the market where you could be
doing things better in fact that's been
my approach to this YouTube channel when
I started there were already millions of
JavaScript tutorials you might even call
it an oversaturated Market but I saw an
opportunity to create shorter faster
content that I thought developers like
me would like just look at a company
like figma they built a design product
that was really only slightly different
than things offered by Adobe at the time
but they addressed the most common pain
points and made a product that people
love a few years later Adobe acquires
them for 20 billion dollars just so they
could make the product suck again now
once you have the general idea of what
you want to build another way to
validate it is to build in public and by
that I mean get on social media and tell
the world what you're building before
you even build it what you'll find is
that there's a lot of other Indie makers
doing the same thing that will support
you and provide feedback oh and by the
way make sure to also follow me on
Twitter because I'll be posting extra
video content there soon that's great
and all but what you really need to do
is validate the idea with your core
audience one product everybody hates but
still pays a hundred dollars a year for
is Microsoft Word what you can do is
find real people or micro influencers on
social media who use this product but
understand its pain points follow these
people like their posts and engage with
them on social media once you've gained
their trust you can then reach out with
a direct message that's like hey I saw
you hate Microsoft Word I'm developing
this new product that solves X and Y
pain points do you want to be the first
one to check it out when it's ready this
is highly surgical direct marketing but
it's also highly effective and people
use it on me for their Tech products and
it works because honestly it's a win-win
if you're creating something that can
make my life better I'd like to know
about it but I'm definitely not going to
click on one of your ads if you get a
lot of people excited that means you're
probably on to something but the reality
is that rejection is very common and you
might get rejected a bunch of times even
if you have a good idea so another way
to validate your idea is to get a bunch
of people to sign up for it before you
even build it you'll see startups do
this all the time with wait lists what
they'll do is focus on marketing first
put together a bunch of promises and
then build up an email list that they
can engage with in the future do not
underestimate the power of an email list
nobody's going to sign up for an email
list unless they truly want what you're
selling on top of that once you have an
email list you can use it to invite
people to a Discord server and from
there you're directly engaging with your
Target customers you can even give them
Early Access in exchange for feedback
about what works and what doesn't it's
way easier to validate ideas when you
have a bunch of collaborators who see
the value in your ideas then as you
start actually delivering on your idea
this community will help promote the
project because you've created something
that adds value to people's lives it's a
win-win for everybody Sam Altman of Y
combinator and openai said the single
most important thing in a startup is to
create a product so good that people
will tell their friends about it but you
won't know if you have a good product
until you actually build it usually when
I have an idea I have one core feature
but then a bunch of optional supporting
features that I want to add on to it
avoid the temptation to ship a whole
bunch of features all at once instead
focus on the core problem to get an MVP
out there quickly and some real users
who can validate the idea software
development almost never goes according
to plan the end result ends up looking
different than the initial Vision
because it's really hard to predict what
the end user actually wants build
something lean and focused get a user
and then build up an Empire from there
you can also launch on websites like
product time to further validate if
people are actually interested in what
you're offering from a technical
standpoint it's usually a good idea to
build apps that have as little friction
as possible like with Firebase I might
start with Anonymous authentication so
the user doesn't have to enter an email
to start using the main features then at
some later points after they've enjoyed
using the app they can upgrade to a full
account if I had a nickel for every time
I decided not to use an app just because
it had a sign in form I would have a
shitload of nickels but the bottom line
is to try to keep your app minimal free
and frictionless especially in the early
game don't even worry about making money
just focus aggressively on making
people's lives better in the mid game
after you have a customer base you can
start adding all those extra features
that your customers want and charge
money for them accordingly and then
finally in the late game you can Lobby
the government for regulations to crush
all the smaller competition now the
final thing I want to say is that even
if your side hustle fails like most of
them do you'll have gained a lot by
grinding through this process you'll
have some new contacts in your Rolodex
you'll have a small community of people
pulling for you you'll have a cool
project on your portfolio that can help
you get a regular developer job you'll
have a bunch of reusable code that you
can use for your next failed project
you'll have a more lean bank account and
finally you'll have the pride in knowing
that you took a risk and tried something
that many people dream about but most
are too afraid to ever try thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one